وقد نعى الحزب استشهاد ثلاثه من مقاتليه
في الجنوب
اللبناني معنا من مرجعيون جنوبيه لبنان
مراسل الجزيره جوني طونس ومن الجليل
الجليل الاعلى جفارا البديري ابدا معك
جوني والتطورات هذا القصف المستمر
وكذلك الطائرات المسيره التي استخدمها
اليوم حزب الله
صحيح محمد تتوالى وتتلاحق التطورات
والتوترات هنا في هذه المناطق الحدوديه
الجنوبيه قبل بعض الوقت شنت المقاتلات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه سلسله من الغارات
الجويه على بلدتي العديسه وكفر كه هنا في
القطاع الشرقي كانت بالفعل غارات عنيفه
بالاضافه الى صواريخ كانت اطلقت قبل بعض
الوقت على دفعتين ايضا من الاراضي
اللبنانيه باتجاه مواقع عسكريه اسرائيليه
في مزارع شبعه في بدايه الامر وبعدها
باتجاه منطقه تلال كفر شوبه ونسمع في هذه
الاثناء بعض الاصوات الناجمه عن القصف
الاسرائيلي المستمر باتجاه عدد من البلدات
ومحيط البلدات الحدوديه الجنوبيه هنا حزب
الله اليوم كان اطلق مسيراته الانقضاض
باتجاه مقر القياده الشماليه وجاء ذلك كما
اعلن ردا على اغتيال القائد الميداني
البارز في وحده الرضوان وسام طويل وايضا
في سياق الردود على اغتيال نائب رئيس
المكتب السياسي في حركه حماس داخل الضحيه
الجنوبيه لبيروت الاسبوع الماضي صالح
العاروري بالاضافه الى عمليات اخرى اعلن
عنها حزب الله خلال ساعات هذا اليوم مسلسل
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه كان بدا صباحا
بغارات ايضا على بلده كفركلا وتحديدا
باتجاه احد المنازل الذي تم تدميره وايضا
الابرز و اللافت هي الغاره التي نفذتها
المسيره الاسرائيليه باتجاه سياره كانت في
بلده خربه سلم قبل وقت قليل من بدايه
مراسم تشييع وسام طويل وقد افاد الدفاع
المدني انه ان هذه العمليه وهذا القصف ادى
الى استشهاد احد الاشخاص داخل هذه السياره
واصابه اخرين بالاضافه الى ايضا مسيره
استهدفت سياره في منطقه الغندور ما ادى
الى استشهاد ثلاثه اشخاص وبعدها نعى حزب
الله ثلاثه من مقاتليه واضح اذا ان الجانب
الاسرائيلي والجيش الاسرائيلي يكثف من
اعتداءاته على الاراضي اللبنانيه باتجاه
حزب الله ومن خلاله باتجاه لبنان اكان
اولا من خلال عمليات الاغتيال التي تحصل
في الاونه الاخيره من خلال الغارات التي
تستهدف مسؤوليين في حزب الله وايضا عناصر
من حزب الله وايضا من خلال الغارات الجويه
التي باتت في المرحله الاخيره تستهدف
مناطق في عمق الجنوب اللبناني ك كما حصل
قبل يومين عندما استهدفت بلده كوثر السياد
على بعد نحو 20 كترا من المنطقه الحدوديه
هناك تحذيرات كانت صدرت في الاونه الاخيره
من مسؤولين من مسؤولين لبنانيين كثر من ان
الجانب الاسرائيلي يسعى الى استدراج حزب
الله واستدراج لبنان الى مزيد من التصعيد
الى مواجهه مفتوحه بشكل او باخر ربطا بما
يجري في قطاع غزه وان هذا الامر قد يؤدي
الى تف جر المنطقه اذا الاوضاع الميدانيه
هنا على حالها من التوتر والتصعيد والترقب
عمليه حزب الله اليوم كانت عمليه لافته
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه مستمره طائرات
الاستطلاع الاسرائيليه يمكننا ان نسمع
اصواتها وصوتها في اجواء المناطق الحدوديه
وحال من الترقب الكبير هنا في الجنوب
اللبناني محمد نعم